okay mm-hmm I guess what is kind of
chill for a little bit wait for
everybody to show up hopefully people
show up
Matthew Jude what's going on guys are
you guys new here I don't never seen you
guys before Leo's here already
people are showing up already all right
whoops I need to mute them okay
oh my goodness I have not read old man
Logan number one yet although I need to
maybe I kind of picked a bad time like
five o'clock in the afternoon maybe that
wasn't the best time to livestream this
but I just got back so I figured what
the hey why not so we'll see if anybody
starts to show up what's going on
Thomas Mason glad you're on Twitter
let's see Twitter calm
okay
Norrin Radd wow you're still here damn
have you been here since the beginning
that's crazy
Rob Bob Bob Bert actually kind of a
funny story when I was in high school
some friend of mine I used to call me
bobert because they couldn't they
couldn't remember if my name was Rob or
if I want to go bye-bye Bobby or Robert
so it's going on dread not dread rod
thank you like it's good to be back I
mean it's also like my mind is running
at a million miles an hour but like my
body's really tired so I'm in like this
this weird in-between spot it's it's
kind of crazy but things going on rich
Watson awesome and here from London it's
going on Paul Jones people are showing
up yay
I wasn't sure people were actually gonna
be able to make it or not I was like
whenever I'll just do a live stream cuz
I know I miss commerce and coffee on
Monday around sorry yesterday on Sunday
because I was driving back and I was
like what the hey might as well go ahead
and and livestream it now so I figured
it couldn't it couldn't hurt them so I'm
just kind of waiting for people to
trickle in I think it'll probably take a
little bit because it's like 5:00 in the
afternoon here in the States
East Coast time and so West Coast it's
like 2:00 in the afternoon or something
like that and so you mean I get a whole
lot of people to show up I'm not really
sure how many people will actually
appear here but I guess we'll find out
here in the next little bit so what's
been going on with you guys
anything new happening which by the way
that reminds me
I've been going through the seeker war
stuff from week two which I need to do a
review on week two I'll probably do like
a week to review on like Wednesday
weekly pull for life or at least a
really long time well awesome I
appreciate it but um I'll probably do
like a review of week two on Wednesday
and then a review of week three on
Thursday so that way we'll get caught up
and then we still have to continue age
of apocalypse
and then there's stories like inferno
stuff like that cuz infernal is exactly
what I thought it was gonna be which is
good like so what's going on Wolfman
Alonso Harris what's going on halogens
ya do ya I feel you man like I've got
I've got all the solicitations from last
week that I need to get caught up with
and then actually need to go to my comic
book store and and pick him up but I was
reading online the reviews and so on
about the issue so far and and like I
said they're exactly what I thought they
would be like Inferno was what I was
hoping it would be Inferno is just like
a different version of how Inferno could
have gone what would have happened if
like the x-men lost if they lost to the
demons that were being controlled by by
oh god what was her name Adeline prior
so I'm really interested to see how it
all plays out but Wolfman I'm just
chilling man I'm as you guys can
probably tell I'm kind of tired but I'm
really I'm really anxious to do this
comics and coffee thing too because it's
fun so like I said we'll see how many
people show up I don't know how many
people are actually gonna gonna show up
here but you know again it's just one of
those one of those funny things I guess
one of those weird things I what if I
showed up on Twitter yeah sort of the
last Jim comics and coffee I can treat
my own tweet that's interesting be kind
of funny if you could rob was inferno in
limbo or Manhattan it was actually in
both um the and we'll talk about this a
little more once we get into like the
the actual Q&A proper when more people
show up here
while 10:30 p.m. in the UK but limbo
originally the way was originally given
us back in the nineteen when when did
limbo originally come out like 1996 I
think no there's no way that's right
there's no way that's right let's see
Marvel and Brno November 1989 okay so it
originally came out in 1989 and right
the way that the inferno was originally
given to us it was actually like like
the story of Madeline Pryor who was Jean
Grey's clone and that was actually it
was a really big deal because we never
had any backstory on Madeline prior she
just like showed up she was just there
one day and Scott Summers was like oh my
god he looked so much like Jean like I'm
just gonna pretend you're Jean and he
would call her Madeline but in his mind
it was Jean Grey and so so of course
they had a kid together and so on and so
forth but the way that it originally
played out like she became the Goblin
Queen and she basically you know it was
like this huge crazy thing but I did two
things the one is of course it gave us
the backstory of Madeline prior into it
established that magic I guess Illyana
Rasputin could jump in between in
between like really I guess so between
like other dimensions and you know the
the main earth-616 but what it looks
like is in the inferno story from secret
Wars it's a different take the question
is what would have happened if like
Madeline Pryor hadn't been defeated if
we had seen
yeah it's oh really straining yeah I
came in through through Indiana so it
was it was like really drizzly the whole
time but I it it looks like it's like a
take on what would have happened if like
Madeline Pryor basically one if the
goblins hadn't been defeated and that's
really an interesting concept with with
inferno it could be really really cool
or it could be really really dumb so I
guess we'll see we'll see how it all
plays out let's see old man Logan the
new Wolverine what do you think I
actually haven't read an old man Logan
yet which I need to but I saw a lot of
questions people are asking me about old
man Logan
like you know what I think about all the
different versions of Wolverine and all
that different kind of stuff and am I
gonna go over them and yes well we're
gonna go what we're gonna do because
what it seems like Marvel is doing is
we're picking like select versions of
characters and they're throwing them in
and so what we're gonna do or at least
what out what I plan to do is we're
gonna go over like the most prominent
members of the Thor Corps and we're
gonna go over the most prominent members
of like all the Hulk's all the versions
of The Incredible Hulk and if what's
going on shady brew and if if old man
Logan is like I think it's gonna be then
we're gonna go over the most prominent
versions of Wolverine that way you know
we don't gets you know reasonable there
won't be you know insane in terms of how
much how much stuff is being thrown out
there at one time
so derbyshire they're pissing down and
every Shia Wolfman Wow guitar let's see
it looks like it's gonna last a little
while as well yeah I kind of sucks talk
more about DC Comics definitely like
this the whole thing of comics explained
is to incorporate more DC comic stuff oh
wow everybody starting to show up now
what's going on Rob thoughts on New
Mutants movie I'm a little unsure about
a new meanest movie um it'll be
interesting but I'm not really sure how
I feel about it um the whole like yes
yes it's weird like I've been like like
gone from like the whole like everything
for the last like five or six days so
from the time that Secret Wars first
came out all that information I guess
from the time that we to came out all
that information up until now like I
have no knowledge on it like I have no
idea what's going on there so anyway um
know what's going on Liam um the whole
thing about this about how much to
explain is to cover DC Comics so we'll
definitely do some more DC comic book
stuff in fact the next the next top 5
that I have is top 5 I guess like like
Lantern wielders it's Laurel I would
like the top 5 lanterns so like my
selection so like Kyle Rayner Hal Jordan
Jon Stewart's Atrocitus stuff like that
like those will be like like well or at
least all are those of my in terms of my
top 5 of all the people who've ever
wielded a Green Lantern or wielded a
Lantern ring at all of any kind
and and kind of go from there so um fun
fact I bought the walking dead number
one at a plus comics in Lexington back
in 2003 best purchase ever yeah dude if
you have a dude if you have the walking
dead number one you need to get Robert
Kirkman to sign that like that would be
nuts
let's see will you be reading the new
Midnighter series um actually no I'm
never heard of it to be honest
well um who produces it who produces the
Midnighters well I mean let's let's look
it up let's see
man neither comic book superhero team
the authority oh okay
so Wildstorm produces it under DC Comics
okay that's interesting any comic book
series I should read well that's that's
actually it's funny that you answer that
you asked that question because with
Secret Wars being the way it is with
everything going about in terms of
Secret Wars with Inferno like at you
know I was mentioning earlier the thing
about Inferno is that they're basically
like retelling a different version of
the Inferno story so I couldn't hurt to
read inferno but really we're gonna
kinda have to take it like a case by
case basis I could tell you like
mainstays like staple stories in Marvel
like I could tell you that in Marvel
Comics you could go with like the
nfinity gauntlet Civil War just like the
regular stuff you know spider-man one
more day just to say that you read it
and you hated it like everybody else you
know it's really kind of hit and miss on
a lot of the stories but again it's it's
kind of difficult to it's difficult to
pinpoint in terms of like DC it appears
on what you're looking for if you're
looking for older stories or you're
looking for new 52 I would say probably
Geoff Johns entire run like Geoff Johns
Green Lantern saga like Green Lantern
epic is the way to go like it's like
it's like some huge comprehensive story
of like a snide and the brightest day
and so on and so forth those are really
really cool stories am I on the comics
let me know have no no I'm not on comic
Cimino actually this this just started
Darth
let's see have I ever heard of the
authority no I mean I never really read
anything by Wildstorm so I've never
really heard of the authority or
anything like that
have you seen Mad Max is a good Mad Max
is really really good like I really
loved it
let's see catch up on sticker Wars now
or you'll be spending weeks catching up
already yeah I know like my next video
it's gonna come out Wednesday so I'm
gonna take like after this is done here
I'm gonna take the rest of tonight and
then I'm gonna take next where I'm sorry
tomorrow and I'm gonna catch up on on
all the secret war stuff I'm gonna try
to get current or as current as I can
and and go from there um
Robb as you heard convergence rewrote
the history of DC do you like the way
the the 'slap-ass and the face with
undoing their entire history well it's
kind of a loaded question thanks a lot
grim grim the great I don't really
consider it a slap in the face so much
as it is I mean this this is like what
the fans asked for like fans wanted like
older stories and so that's what they
gave him what is that comic in the
background that see this is what happens
when you have a TD like you focus on
like everything at the same time this is
fantastic for anyone number two this is
the history of Doctor Doom um anyway
it's a giant-sized issue
it's what things asked for a fan said
they wanted older stories and so DC gave
them older stories and then fans were
getting angry about it I never really
understood that but no I mean I don't
think there's anything wrong with
convergence I mean the new 52 continuity
in terms of like that universe is it
gonna stay we're just gonna get like
well at least that version of Superman
is gonna be the main Superman although
they're changing it up because we're
taking its powers away but again you
know we'll see what happens um what
happened to the definitive Superman
video I'm still working on it let's see
what Rob what do you what do I think
will happen if Fantastic Four and x-men
fail at the box office could they go
into the MCU possibly but I don't see
Fox giving over Fox is not going to get
rid of the rights to the x-men don't
make x-men movies until the end of time
because it's just going to be a cash
grab every single time an extra movie
comes out
because Fox is the only one making it
people are gonna go see it it's their
only source for x-men material so it
makes sense unless basically unless like
Marvel somehow has the rights to
actually in the animated series and they
bring the X Ben the animated series back
then that could take away from the
especially they made like an animated
movie based on x-men the animated series
that would take away from the box office
of the x-men film and if they
consistently did that it could take away
from fox may give the rights back I'm
not I'm not really sure but right now
Fox doesn't really have anything to lose
by keeping the rights I mean you know
they can keep making movies people will
keep going to see them and that's that I
mean it really isn't a whole lot of
reason to give him back favorite secret
worst high in so far um man it's kind of
a hard one I see that the problem is is
they're not complete and so I mean and
this is kind of one of the things I
didn't like about what Marvel did with
Secret Wars is they're releasing it like
in segments they get Planet Hulk number
one here then Planet Hulk number two
there then plant Hope number three there
and someone I'm not really sure I enjoy
that whole thing but um I would say that
my favorite so far would probably be
like Planet Hulk I like that one so so
much because you have like Joe fix it I
think was Joe fix-it
that version of The Incredible Hulk as
though that's a really cool version so I
really like I really like that like the
story so far
well I cover jla/avengers crossover
comic I'm a but right now it's all like
sticker Wars and whatever DC is gonna do
with Superman and whatever other
characters they have so it's it's like
it's like we're really tied up at the
moment because keep in mind guys like I
mean we've we've got to do eight we got
to finish Age of Apocalypse which will
probably fingers crossed
well had that finished this week and
then we have to start on inferno we've
got to do where monsters well like we
have to do like all the stuff that
Secret Wars is doing like we got to do
all the old stories and then we got to
cover Secret Wars because the problem is
like with inferno like Inferno just
picks up it just says well the x-men
lost and so people are like well let me
nah no I mean it doesn't give me like
the original I don't understand how this
is like how does this tie in and people
just don't know what the hell's going on
so we've got to go we've got to explain
the original Inferno and then say okay
this is where the story differs instead
of the x-men winning the x-men loose and
just kind of go from there so let's see
what Mike is this is a re 20 microphone
I cover it is who makes a Kevin burr who
is but anyway yeah it's Inori 20 so you
can just you can just Google re 20
microphone am I still going into the gym
yes could you do Nathaniel Richards
explained on a Monday request if it's
popular enough I mean Marvel requests
well I guess comics request Monday is
like your all's day to decide what
videos go up I mean I don't determine
that I don't make that decision that's
that's you all so it was popular it'll
go up there let's see who is your
favorite indie book um let's see my
favorite indie book is definitely
probably The Walking Dead and that's
that's my favorite one at the moment
let's see how are you today I'm doing
pretty good
do you think do I think they will reveal
an infinity stone in the Doctor Strange
movie that's coming out definitely
Doctor Strange is too big of a character
for them to not reveal an infinity stone
because Doctor Strange is involved in
like the mystics and magic and crazy
dimensions and all that kind of stuff
and so they I mean he's the perfect
person to like introduce an infinity
stone with I don't understand why they
wouldn't so it'd be kind of weird um
let's see do i watch Game of Thrones yes
I love Game of Thrones uh Rob you're so
cool I appreciate it
what are your favorite exercises in the
gym mine's cleans and jerks um mine is
the is the Oh God deadlifts and then
before that it was actually the bent
over barbell curls but I think deadlifts
worked the back much much better and
they worked the back the glutes the
hamstrings like they work like like that
whole like this whole like mid area
everything from like the knees up to the
ABS like it's a really really cool
workout the bench press is a classic
squat strangely enough I don't mind
squats they're not the greatest like
they kind of suck but at the same time
like they're so good for you that you
know I kind of enjoy the element of
doing those um let me a few other
exercises here and there but for the
most part like I use a workout routine
where it works like the most muscle
groups at one time because that's a
realistic way of lifting like people
like whenever you lift like if you go to
lift something heavy you don't just lift
with your arms in isolation like you
lift with your legs and your lower back
and your
arms in your chest and your you know
shoulders and all that kind of stuff so
I mean I like to work then work as many
muscles at one time as I can you know so
anyway um who made the drawings behind
me I can't tell you but I got them
commissioned at New York comic-con
I forgot my coffee I did not forget my
coffee eyes since I just finished a 23
hour drive I've had more coffee than you
can imagine and so I am I am not
drinking coffee
it'll be Sunday before I drink coffee
again so let's see where did I'm at
where do that Iron Man sketch come from
I want to buy from ya know I'm not
telling you guys let's see just came
across the channel I love it well I'm
glad you love it let's see just came
into workouts and coffee yes this
episode it has nothing to do with comics
we're talking about exercises and coffee
so let's see what did you think of this
week's Game of Thrones episode I
actually haven't seen it yet so what's
your opinion of the Spider Man renew
your vows I'm actually haven't read it
yet is it out already
I don't think spider-man renew your vows
is out already let's see how much is
your collection how much of your
collection is physical and digital most
of it's digital because I use Marvel
unlimited so I just go directly to
Marvel unlimited and just read it there
or comiXology um but I have a few you
know here and there I mean I've got you
know like most of its in storage like
all the old stuff like like New Mutants
number 98 like the old Green Lantern
stuff the cable and Deadpool run like
all that kind of stuff like that's all
in storage so let's see this is a
favorite among the spider-man candidates
as far as I knew there was only a so
Butterfield but are there more if
there's more like let me know because
I'm pretty sure that's a Butterfield is
the only one that uh that is playing
spider-man um let's see scroll back up
can we talk about the flash season to
you what do you guys okay what do you
guys think about the flash because we
talked about that during the weekly pool
what do you guys think about the flash
like I'm actually pretty psyched
I think the flash is going to be I think
the season 2 is gonna be pretty awesome
I think we're ready
I'm gonna see like the flash running
through like like I don't know other
dimensions other realities something
like that but I don't know if we're ever
gonna actually like to see him come back
or I guess we will but I don't know it's
it's weird I think that this season is
going to focus on other dimensions on
other realities which is cool because I
think that he's going to like expand and
it's going to grow um is anybody else
having a hard time hearing me um if
you're if you guys can hear me fine then
that Alice cape guy will be fun so um
which comic book movie pissed me off the
most
hmm I mean none really I mean none
really made me angry after watching it I
was just like man that sucks
um I mean I guess maybe like the way
they the way they did Deadpool and one
OK Wolverine Origins was was like crap
like Wolverines origins was it was a
terrible movie I didn't really get like
angry walking out of it I was just like
man I wasted my money and that was kind
of it so let's see I can't wait for
Supergirl yeah I think Supergirl is
gonna be pretty solid too so love the
flash so much better than arrow I think
they're actually pretty even um I think
they're pretty solid in terms of how
they how they came together um it's cool
they decided to cross them over see I
think that's where like DC's bread and
butter is like I think that's where
where DC's really strong is having like
a strong TV universe like the strong TV
universe is is like really worth or so I
mean Marvel has the movies and they have
Netflix the ODC has like the flash they
have arrow they should bring in
Supergirl they should bring in
Constantine they should bring in Gotham
all those things should fold in together
for a for a really cool cinematic
universe but I guess we'll find out
whether it will or not in the Doctor
Strange movie do you think the eye of a
komodo is going to be an infinity
catalyst and the Marvel movie like the
tesseract Cosmic Cube I think so I think
that the the eye of agamotto is like
probably the single most important
artifact that dr. strange has because it
let him do so much stuff I mean it lets
some open portals across the world lets
him do all different you know all
different things I guess across the
cosmos and all kinds of stuff
it's a very very important artifact I
would say if we're gonna see him equip
any kind of artifact it'll be the eye of
agamotto and so it makes sense that they
would make that make like the core the
actual power behind the eye of agamotto
a I'm sorry I was gonna say a secret war
and infinity stone that would make
perfect sense that I mean I'd like I'd
love to see that like I think that'd be
cool but again you know it's um it's
really just kind of up in the air
I think Adam Hutton hey from UK Rob
what's going on Adam
do you like Hal Jordan John Steuart
Kilowog Hal Rainer most as a Green
Lantern actually we're gonna grown over
that list so I'm not gonna tell you what
my list is right now but we will go over
that list very very soon
if the Living Tribunal and the one above
all were in the MCU what event were to
happen for them to appear Oh God
well you're talking about like a
multiversal event like you would have to
be something on on a multiversal scale
and we haven't seen any multiversal
event we haven't seen a universal event
yet like we're waiting for an infinity
war to see a universal event take place
um I would say if we were gonna see like
a multiversal event mm maybe like Thanos
capturing like the heart of the universe
like that I think would make sense that
that would be possible I mean they'd
have to do a whole story around it and
everything but it'd have to be have to
be like two parts like infinity war but
I could see that being the case bringing
the the one above all out of out of
hiding and bringing in you know the
Living Tribunal but again I don't know I
mean it's it's really I mean let me
Tribunal he'll probably appear if he if
Marvel's gonna include him at all we may
see him in the in the infinity war event
because he appeared in Infinity Gauntlet
so that kind of makes sense but um have
you read any new Star Wars titles yes I
read Star Wars number one and number two
and I have Darth Vader number one
actually sitting over there which I need
to get that signed at New York Comic Con
along with all my variant titles of my
comics so far they're cool like I like
what they're doing so far they're
basically like filling in the gaps you
know like a Star Wars number one takes
place between a new hope and Return of
the Jedi
you know Darth Vader number one Princess
Leia number one all that stuff takes
place between Return of the Jedi and
Empire
rikes back so it seems like what they're
doing is we're sending yes here is Star
Wars Episode seven but the comics are
gonna fill in the gas and they're
basically erasing the expanded universe
that existed and they're creating their
own expanded universe which isn't a bad
idea
it's actually a really cool concept so
um let's see
are you team teamcap or teamironman in
the Civil War who I'm team Iron Man
Booth's I'm a huge fan of Iron Man from
Civil War Ryan Chapman everybody go
check out ryan chapman chapman ryan
chapman yeah go check it out oh I forgot
to post a link in the comments or in the
description for a channel however we'll
do that next week yeah well um let's see
Rob do you think a Green Lantern TV show
could happen definitely and I think it
should I think a Green Lantern TV show
would be really solid um see here's
here's like here's a kicker I mean the
DC's basically set the stage like we saw
Barry Allen run to coast city so we know
coast city exists we've seen like
multiple references to Hal Jordan so we
know how Jordan exists and in fact I
think Bennie pointed it out the Vinny
said that in the in the cinematic I'm
sorry in the and the flash TV show that
they established that that Hal Jordan
already vanished so presumably he's
already been inducted into the Green
Lantern Corps so he may return possibly
in the second season or have a cameo as
the Green Lantern I think they'd be a
good way to do it I think the best way
for them to do it is to test the water
with the Green Lantern especially coming
off the heels of the Ryan Reynolds film
while Ryan Reynolds played a pretty good
Hal Jordan the movie itself in terms of
the script that was written for his
character it was not written very well
and so while Ryan Reynolds did a great
job everybody else kind of screwed the
pooch and so I think that them
introducing him and like a cameo version
would be pretty solid it'd be pretty
awesome but not introducing him in a
cameo version and just jumping into a TV
show would be kind of a kind of a big
gamble it'd be a lot of money a lot of
time a lot of writing and it might all
just kind of go away so yeah we'll see
what's up let's see do you sometimes
have problems reading comics off of
Marvel unlimited sometimes that won't
allow me to download comics offline um
and I don't do that I usually just read
directly um Noren I appreciate you
coming out man I will see you later
I usually read directly off of Marvel
unlimited um Omar Morgan welcome and
this is your first time here yeah again
you know it's I've never really used
model unlimited unlike the iPad or the
iPhone I just read it directly on my PC
I don't really have a reason to read it
on an iPad my iPad is reserved for like
my books and stuff like that you know
all the Harry Potter books and and I
read like The Fault in Our Stars like
that book sucked but um you know yeah
so let's see how will the defender
specifically daredevil be brought in to
the rest of the MCU
we don't know that they will we don't
know that they will be brought in to the
rest of the MCU we think they will and I
think daredevil disturbed now I'll have
an appearance in the Captain America
Civil War I don't think he does I want
to say that I thought he had an
appearance on the set though I could be
wrong though but I think that um that if
they are folded in then we'll see them
kind of appearing in stages throughout
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and we
probably really won't see them joining
full-on until phase 3 or I guess until
face ya know until phase 4 yeah I think
phase 4 is and we'll see them like
full-on up here and the amount of
cinematic universe but again you know we
don't really know I mean they could
appear in phase 3 they could have little
cameos and like and black panther they
could have little cameos and you know
some other film and thor ragnarok or
something like that I don't know I man
truth at this point it's just really
kind of like a like a crapshoot in terms
of what model is going to do with their
films usually they keep films isolated
to the characters like Thor Ragnarok
will probably focus only on Asgard but
that is that's it's not impossible I
mean if you guys remember and the Thor
Ragnarok event he called on Tony Stark
and Captain America and they actually
showed up to help him out so almost
anything's possible let's see there's a
few Locke were talking to a camera no
because I feel like I'm talking to you
guys like it doesn't really feel awkward
at all if it feels like I'm having a
face-to-face conversation but not really
I don't know if that makes any sense
Leonard Holly I appreciate it
rest in peace Jackie Chan Jackie Chan's
not dead no way now what do you think
about the new series in battle world
what do you mean like the battle world
series itself or a series starting in
battle world
what do you what do I think about Batman
in game Batman in game was pretty solid
but I mean there's definitely room to to
like keep expanding um there's
definitely room to kind of keep going I
mean I guess the question is you know is
you know it is Batman dead but you know
I mean we've got Darkseid war and
Batman's alive so take that for what
it's worth that's really kind of like a
big like DC screw the pooch like they
basically like they spoiled their own
spoiler everybody makes any sense well I
guess it's I mean any Batman story
written by Scott Snyder is gonna be good
so you know I've got no real qualms with
it as long as he writes I'm sure you
could just write Batman Forever and
nobody's gonna ask any questions but um
I mean it's sometimes I think DC just
doesn't know what they're doing let's
see who do I think Martin Freeman will
play in civil war will do continue
Herald of Galactus series I love that
series um I don't know probably I mean
there really aren't that many heralds of
Galactus left to go over I mean I guess
maybe there was a lot maybe but it was
really just kind of a fun serious to do
sporadically it wasn't meant to be like
an ongoing thing but um I mean I don't
know who might rent Martin Freeman's
gonna play I've been trying to figure
that out
I mean Baron Zemo is already covered or
I guess how museum OHS already covered
they're not going to give us like Baron
Zemo um I think maybe he'll play a
senator but the senator that appeared in
civil war wasn't it wasn't that
important he was just there for the sake
of the Civil War event and he talked to
she hold for a little while I mean
there's far more important characters
besides a ham that they could use I mean
I doubt they'll use them for name of the
Submariner so oh I mean I have no real
idea let's see do what do you think
about all the leaked videos and photos
from the Suicide Squad
isn't that sprung the film I mean
honestly it's a DC based film it
probably needs all the help I can get
but you know it may stand on its own two
feet to I don't know I don't really know
I mean I've never been that avid of a
fan of The Suicide Squad like when they
announced and they said they're doing a
Suicide Squad movie I was kind of like
I'm not might go check it out I mean
I've never I was never that avid of a
Suicide Squad fan um I would say that in
the end if they're going to is they're
gonna release photos and if they're
gonna release videos then they're
looking for looking for fan reaction
they're looking for a public reaction
and I would say that means they're a
little skeptical about the success of
the film they're a little worried about
whether or not it'll actually succeed I
could be wrong but you know I think it
might be they might be a little bit
worried I would love to go to
Creamfields but alas I don't want to go
all the way - yeah I don't wanna go out
wait a year um let's see
oh my god so many questions coming in so
fast do you think Suicide Squad Joker
looks cool I think he looks like a like
a felon like an ex-con um I think
they've spent - I think they probably
try too hard to make him different from
the other Joker's like like they didn't
want him to look like Steve Englehart
Joker um they should have mean they
should have it's weird because I think
the DC sat down and they said okay like
the Jack Nicholson Joker from back in
the day is like Steve Englehart Joker
two-degree the I guess Heath Ledger
Joker is the old-school sadistic Joker
the the Joker they're trying to give us
here I think is like a combination
between like the crazy Joker and the
goofy Joker but also like the sadistic
Joker I'm not really sure I don't know
if they're trying to make the Joker more
like relatable if they're trying to make
the Joker more human I have no idea but
in the end I mean Jared Leto can
probably play The Joker pretty well it's
just one of those weird things we're
gonna have to like sit down and watch
the movie and in order to decide whether
or not we like this version of the Joker
or not I mean there's really no it's I
mean all we have are like pictures so
there's really no way to know whether or
not the Joker's gonna be good enough
let's see what do I think about kingdom
come Kingdom Come was a great series um
I loved the idea in Kingdom Come when
Superman was basically like I give up on
humanity that was a really cool concept
to see Superman just basically walk away
to basically just say like humanity's
virtually irredeemable my
nothing I can do I mean Superman like
always did what he didn't always do this
best like he always tried to help people
but in the end like it was just kind of
like you know he was like just the heck
with it
I think the whole idea of like Wonder
Woman showing up and Wonder Woman being
like you got to come back you know and
and that kind of thing I think was kind
of silly
Batman forming his own like cabal so to
speak was really cool but Kingdom Come I
think was a story best left on its own
it was a story best left out there by
itself I'm not really sure I agree with
the idea of them like bringing it back
in but it doesn't mean that DC's gonna
screw it up they may very well do a
really cool job with it in terms of
expanding on it and giving us more in
that the Kingdom Come continuity if they
choose to but again it's just kind of
it's kind of up in the air so um let's
see what do you think about the Civil
War line up in the MCU well I'm kind of
on the fence um you know I think that
the problem with the if the the stream
is locking you guys let me know does
anybody have any lagging problems with
the audio in the video um I think that
with the with with age of Ultron the
problem they had is they had so much
going on they had so much happening so
much moving at such a fast pace that it
was just kind of like it was crazy it
was up in the air it was it was
absolutely nuts and it seemed like
things were moving so quick with Captain
America's Civil War we might have that
problem we might not we might have and
lower the quality I think that with the
with Captain America's Civil War we may
not have that problem it may be written
in a way to where we have like all these
characters you know introducer all these
characters thrown in but we don't really
have any insanity going on here I mean
like things moving so kind of like crazy
and silly and goofy and stuff like that
again it's it's you know it depends you
know I mean I guess it really it really
does depend on the writing the Russos
are solid I mean the Russos are really
really good directors and so either way
I think it'll be a great movie I don't
think it'll be it'll be too wild I think
having like basically the entire roster
of the Avengers - The Incredible Hulk is
going to produce a pretty solid film so
um let's see
new to new 52 Justice League reading
order please um I mean just start with
number one if you wanted to I mean you
could read quite literally like I mean
number numbers like 1 through I think 6
or 7 maybe 8 deal with the formation of
the Justice League and it literally like
that's the first time that a lot of the
heroes are meeting each other in the new
52 the first time that that Hal Jordan
meets Batman for example the first time
that Batman meets the flash the first
time that Batman meets Superman there's
actually a fight between the two of them
which is really cool you know from there
you can kind of jump forward you can I
mean you can get into stories like like
the you know the the Atlanta story I
don't really remember what that story
was but I don't really think that was
necessary um it's it's weird I mean it's
like a series of ongoing stories but
they're not really necessary and true
that I'd say just I'd say start with
issues number one and just kind of pick
and choose what you want
after the initial like basis the initial
formation of the Justice League let's
see can you do a history of the question
um I mean I don't see why not I mean
throw it up on the request for Marvel
request I guess come across one day and
and we'll see what's up have I ever been
in a fight yeah I mean I'm in fights how
do you feel about Marvel not releasing
the extended cut of Avengers age of
Ultron for blu-ray well as far as I know
there is no extended cut like the
version we saw was the extended cut like
the other one was the shorter version
like the one that that um that oh god
his name Joss Whedon initially wanted to
produce was a shorter one you know this
one is is not nearly I mean this this is
like the extended version you're Tyrone
Magnus is cool if you guys don't know
who Tyrone Magnus is you guys should go
over to his channel and just be like how
many's explained sent me here i taro
Magnus says he has really funny realize
every action videos let's see do I think
something like the Stanford tragedy will
occur in the Civil War movie
I don't know see that was my big
question is it's like what's the
catalyst I'm in truth I think the
catalyst was like age of Ultron like I
think age of Ultron is the Stanford
incident I think that is like the
Stanford conflict you know that's that's
natural blowing up Stanford Connecticut
that is the New Warriors jumping into a
situation just going full-bore and
saying attack you know and not really
thinking about the consequences you know
that I think is is the Stanford incident
that's the powder keg you know that just
sets off the whole you know Civil War
conflict so again I guess we'll really
find out but I could be wrong we may see
just like a Stanford Connecticut thing
um let's see
so many questions coming in like I'm so
tired but there's so many questions
coming in it's crazy it's hard to focus
any thoughts on the Doctor Strange movie
oh wow I mean I'm excited for it I love
Doctor Strange
I think Doctor Strange usually he's a
rough character he's a difficult
character to do is very difficult to
write Doctor Strange in a story that's
good because he's so powerful and so the
question is what kind of a story can you
put him in that will make him compelling
that we're here where fans won't
somebody just say well why doesn't dr.
strange just fix it you know why didn't
he just like wave his hands and you know
do as a lawn thing and and that's it you
know um it's tough to do um I'm hoping
that I mean in the in the and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe we already know
Doctor Strange is established like we
already know he exists we found that out
with what's his name and Captain America
with agent Sitwell we found that out
with Captain America too whenever he was
talking about everybody that shield or I
guess that Hydra was monitoring as
potential threats he ran off Stephen
strange his name and so we know he
exists we know he's probably dr. strange
at this point in time we don't know if
they're gonna give us his backstory if
they're gonna tell us about him being a
neurosurgeon him meeting the ancient one
Friday Mordo so on and so forth we don't
know if the film's gonna focus on Mort
oh there's a lot of things up in the air
here I would say their best bet probably
the safest bet in truth would be to just
pick up with the very beginning just to
say he was a neurosurgeon he was
arrogant and got into a car wreck lost
the use of his hands eventually found
the ancient one found out Merida was
trying to overthrow the ancient one he
helped to defeat Mordo became the
sorcerer supreme so
it seems to me like that be the safe bed
that'd be the best bet to go in terms of
his characters history but there's also
really compelling characters like
Dormammu but again you know it's that's
a character they would have to kind of
introduce over time I could see Dormammu
appearing and like dr. strange too
I wouldn't see to her mama when dr.
strange one because he's such a huge
villain like if Dormammu were to become
a villain and the Doctor Strange film it
would take the combined efforts of the
Avengers and the guardians of the galaxy
and a litany of other characters that we
haven't seen yet in addition to Doctor
Strange to successfully beat Dormammu so
it'd be it'd be nuts yeah he's like
wizard level 9 you know let's see quit
your job you don't need a social life we
need more videos the ultimate ultimate
question is Marvel or DC well it used to
be Marvel like I used to be like Marvel
and that was it but you know in getting
into and reading like new 52
I'm definitely DC now so or at least a
big fan that's as much of a fan as I can
be I mean I do this for a living like
this this is what I do for a living like
I make youtube videos about comic books
um let's see
think it will be better than the 1980s
Doctor Strange movie I don't think so I
mean I don't think anything will be
better than the 1980s Doctor Strange
movie for those of you guys who haven't
seen it the 1980s Doctor Strange movie
it's probably the greatest movie of all
time I mean probably the best movie ever
made in the history of all movies even
better than Mad Max fury road which by
the way is the best movie of all time
regardless what anybody says I will say
that's one of the greatest movies ever
made like for me it's like a No Country
for Old Men and then like neverending
story and then Saving Private Ryan and
then Mad Max fury road and then like
jaws or something like that or no then
like The Lion King I think we're coming
number five but I don't accessible and
as the likes of The Avengers no I don't
think so because the Avengers had such a
huge buildup I mean we had Iron Man 1 we
had the Incredible Hulk
we had Thor we had Captain America we
had like this and like they were all
connected like we had post-credit scenes
and they were all connected so we all
knew this was building up into something
huge plus
the end of Iron Man one it was like Nick
Fury's like a vineyards initiative and
so we knew the Avengers was coming but
with this like with with Superman versus
Batman I mean it'll be big it'll be huge
it'll be a huge blockbuster film I just
don't think it's gonna be like the
Avengers level blockbuster film I think
it'll be solid and I'll go see it but
then Lord of the Rings trilogy yeah Lord
of the Rings trilogy was pretty solid
too the road warrior was really good I
agree the road warrior was good but also
don't forget Beyond Thunderdome like
Beyond Thunderdome was pretty solid too
who runs Bartertown let's see hey Rob
sorry to spam but I'm curious where do
you think old man Logan is going next
well I haven't read the story yet I
haven't read the solicitation from
Secret Wars so that one I really can't
answer but I would say that I have no
idea I mean it's on my list like I'll
read that tonight and and again like I
said for those of you guys who were who
were just joining us what I'll probably
do is the airplane is like top 10 but
it's not top 5 I'll probably end up
doing like a review for week 2 on
Wednesday and then do a review for week
3 on Thursday that we were caught up and
then we'll finish out Age of Apocalypse
and and go from there then we'll jump
into like Inferno will jump into where
monsters dwell which slide all that
stuff so that it all makes sense in
sigur Wars so let's see so Rob I just
sort of the channel and the vids suck do
you have any pointers and make better
videos I guess I don't know I mean it's
it's it's look guys I love it when you
guys ask me questions like how do I grow
a YouTube channel like how do I make my
channel grow how do I make my channel
expand look at the end of the day I
think I was just in the right place at
the right time and and that like that's
that's that's my attitude for how I got
where I am like I was just in the right
place at the right time and I just made
the right kind of videos and you guys
loved my videos and and that's the hat I
mean I can't give you guys like a
winning recipe I can't I can't line out
like you know do these three things
and and people will love your content I
mean one like one of the big things you
can do is answer questions a lot of
people have I mean I think that one of
the cornerstones in my video is
answering questions that people have I
mean that's you know it's people want to
know like what's inferno okay let's
explain inferno I mean that's the kind
of thing that that latches on but um can
I hit your vapor but it's it's I don't
know it's it's um my voice my voice
brought you guys huh how many of you
guys are here because of my voice like
just just say this type like voice in
the chat if you're here because of my
voice because I'm curious I'm just kind
of interested I mean is it a is it a
very sexy voice to you guys you guys dig
the voice that I have I mean I never
really thought it was that great of a
voice but you know I mean I guess it
really just depends let's see DC versus
Marvel physically stronger characters Oh
God um I mean marvel's got Incredible
Hulk Marvel's got a voice voice voice
voice voice everybody's like boy oh my
god holy cow god's voice explained oh
man you guys are here for my voice
smooth is better that is the greatest
that's that's amazing
rocks voice explained they were like
like 200 people were just like voice for
his voice voice that was awesome that
was hilarious I forgot what I was
talking about
it's a booming yet calming voice yeah
like I was talking to Scott over a
nursing and I was like okay dude I was
like tell me what it is about my voice
like I don't understand he was like well
he's like he's like when you talk it's
like you're just compelled to listen
like yeah Rob like yeah like that's a
cool story Rob like yeah man like I'm so
like immersed in what you're talking
about and it's just funny to me it's
it's it just kind of it just kind of
cracks me up let's see how well Phoenix
force play in battle world well let's
see that's the kicker I mean as far as
we know right now like Scott Summers is
the only Phoenix force again I'm not I'm
not necessarily caught up so for those
of you guys who are currently caught up
if that was revealed then you know bear
with me since I don't I don't know but
as far as we know Scott Summers is the
only person in possession of the Phoenix
force and so I don't know I mean I'm
curious I'm actually really really
curious I would say I would say we may
end up seeing Scott Summers like you
know going away and the Phoenix force
like taking on the role of a cosmic
entity within the realm of the new super
wars battle world but again I don't know
I mean I could be wrong here so seeing
Barry White songs actually I mean I am I
am a pretty good singer well I think I
am I used to be anyway before I got into
cigarettes but I sing I sing in all
state a couple times when I was in high
school and and yeah that was really fun
so I was a baritone I was a cross
between a tenor and a bass and it was
really fun I was actually in the same
chorus class as a friend of mine um
named Lauren like man it was that chorus
class man oh my god yes memories it was
mmm it was interesting am i excited
about ant-man
I see we were talking about that before
we you know mean the guys we're talking
about
ant-man and the question was like is
anybody excited for her for him does
anybody care my personal opinion yes I
really want to see ant-man the question
I have though is did Marvel like screw
the pooch with ant-man because an in
truth the way they set it up like
initially Avengers 2 age of Ultron was
supposed to be like the end of phase 2
but then they brought an ant-man and
that's gonna be the end of phase 2 I
think they brought that in at the wrong
time and truth and man should have come
much earlier ant-man should have come a
while from you know it should have been
like after Iron Man 1 but between the
Incredible Hulk and the reason why is
because with the I quit smoking I use my
ISA grin now like tobacco is just that's
in hindsight like I've been I've been
clean for like two years and it's it
amazes me like how bad
cigarettes smell now but but anyway I
feel like you know a man should have
come after Iron Man one but before the
Incredible Hulk because now that I mean
with with Avengers 2 age of Ultron
people were like okay like the Ultron
hype like the Ultron hype was real like
you guys remember it was nuts everybody
was like Avengers 2 oh thank you
everybody was so excited for it and then
you know following this we have Captain
America 3 Civil War following Captain
America 3 Civil War we have like
everything in phase 3 we've got Miss
Marvel we've got the Inhumans we've got
guardians of the galaxy - we've got
Black Panther we've got Doctor Strange
you know there's no room for a character
like ant-man if so in truth
ant-man could be a sleeper it could very
well be a movie that just kind of sneaks
in and then boom blows up at the box
office and it's absolutely incredible
but in truth I think that they've
they've built movies up so well and
they've given us such like awesome you
know awesome awesome movie so far that I
think that ant-man is gonna feel like
Iron Man 1 and because it's gonna feel
like Iron Man 1 which was like eight
years ago it's gonna fall short people
are gonna say well this is not up to the
standard of Marvel Cinematic Universe
movies now because they've increased the
standards
so much 90s megamix yes watching Nuggets
knows what's going on but um but yeah I
think that's that's gonna be that's
gonna be the big thing now I'm not
really sure but again you know I mean I
could be wrong you know it could be that
ant-man it's gonna be a stellar movie it
might you know it might blow people away
my you know smash box office records and
all that kind of stuff I have no idea I
mean we'll see I mean I'm gonna go see
it and I'm not gonna I'm not gonna not
go see it let's see what do you all we
already talked about that that's Morgan
Freeman molecule man merged with Doctor
Doom making him like crazy powerful see
I thought that was the case but have
they confirmed that or not because I
thought that was the case let's see
guardians of the galaxy though Rob yeah
Deadpool
yeah that's true Deadpool's coming out
to UM Doctor Strange has Tilda Swinton
as the ancient one what do you think Rob
loved the show coming in from the UK
Tilda Swinton isn't she like the she's
like that older lady isn't she
oh she played Gabriel and Constantine I
think so this oh yes
Tilda Swinton let me tell you something
man might tilde and Tilda Swinton if
she's and she's playing a character in a
movie
I will go watch that movie like I don't
care what that movie is it could be a
movie of Tilda Swinton watching paint
peel and I will go and watch that movie
and it'll be like the most artistic
movie I've ever seen and it'll be like
this really highlights what acting is
the ability to like be yourself but
watch something miserable take places
for you I don't know um Tilda Swinton is
gonna play the ancient one is that is
that confirmed I mean hold on let's
let's Google that real quick
cuz I haven't heard anything about that
Tilda Swinton ancient one in
negotiations to join dr. strange um just
to say okay reportedly up for the
ancient one I mean I'm down with that
I mean I'll go see it I think she'd be a
great version she's hot yeah and she's a
she's a very attractive woman
um yeah I mean I'd be down to see her
play the ancient one I mean I'd have no
problem with it
what happened in pepper potts we don't
know all we know is captain or I guess
our man three ended and that was it so
we have no idea what pepper pot says we
know she's alive I mean we know she's
not dead you know they talked about her
a little bit during Captain America I'm
sorry during Avengers age of Ultron so I
mean you know like she's not dead she's
alive I mean they had a little bit of a
debate but as far as we know she's still
just running you know Stark Industries
so maybe we'll see her at least I hope
I'll see her a little more but we might
not so I guess you know well we'll find
out um Rob I dreamed that DC would
scroll back up so many questions coming
in I dream that DC announced that the
Green Lantern movie is canon and some
version of Emerald Twilight happened
would that be a good idea uh I mean I'm
not really sure if I were DC at this
point I distance myself from the Green
Lantern movie I would say yeah we made
it but you know don't worry about it
like the Green Lantern is like like DC's
version of Howard the Duck when Marvel
made that movie back in the day like do
I think pendants will be included in the
Civil War movie now I don't think so I
mean there's no reason I mean the reason
of my penance the penance was it was
kind of a stupid idea of it the reason
why penance came about was because it
was like Robby Baldwin like the result
of all the hassle Robby Walden went
through and like all the the misery and
all the crap that he'd been given over
the years and like how everything just
kind of went crazy I mean is that you
know ultimately resulted in him kind of
losing his mind and becoming penance you
know but we don't know who he is he
doesn't exist so far and so there's
really no reason to incorporate that
element and the Green Lantern is poopy
and the Green Lantern's poop that movie
was poop who was poop and pee
let's see Batman versus I am an answer
my question please rob was answer my
question
Batman vs Iron Man probably Batman I
mean well if Batman gets no prep time if
he has no prep time they just randomly
mean then definitely Iron Man let's see
Batman and Superman versus the whole MCU
probably Batman okay if Batman has prep
time and then he joins Superman and they
fight the whole Marvel Cinematic
Universe so far definitely Batman is
Superman they would lay waste to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so far the
only person left standing they were
presented challenge against the two of
them will be the Incredible Hulk and you
know that would be difficult now we're
not including Doctor Strange or Captain
Marvel or any of those because they're
not here yet but I mean like at this
point right now I would say like
definitely definitely Batman is Superman
I need to narrate a Marvel movie it'd be
fun you know maybe it'd be interesting
to attend a rate um let's see what do
you think will happen to the X titles
after Secret Wars I think they'll be
kind of like shunted into the background
I think they'll be just kind of like
slammed in the back and that'll be that
I don't really think they're going to
amount to anything I mean what reason is
there for them to amount to anything I
mean there's no reason to do anything
with them I mean they're just kind of
there and so stuff will happen and and
that's it but they're not gonna receive
anywhere near like the forefront like I
mean that's what we have a till and
rising that's why the Inhumans are
becoming like the mainstay the Inhumans
are replacing the x-men both in the
comics and in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so let's see do you think
Deadpool could take down the entire DC
Universe hmm so that's a good question
see the reason why Deadpool was able to
kill off so many characters and Deadpool
kills the Marvel Universe is because he
was familiar with him he knew what their
powers were in the DC he doesn't know
what their powers were but he can heal
from anything so I'd say yes I'd say DC
I say you could probably take down the
entire DC Universe which by the way that
needs to happen somebody at Marvel and
DC like to do or like Alonso like one of
you guys needs to like sit down and say
okay
Deadpool kills the DC Universe let's
make that story happen okay how many of
you guys would buy a story called
Deadpool kills the DC Universe like how
many of you would buy that story um are
you the next Robin for bad flick I wish
I wish I were playing a horse are
playing robin format flick i would
happily play it Robin I'd be like the
like the fattest Robin ever I would be
like I'm coming Batman like I'm common
man just hold your horses man I'm had a
breath
let's see rob with the with most
powerful superheroes now Dennis Secret
Wars how am I will renew them again or
will they be dead forever do we knew
them again like they'll definitely come
back yeah see like everybody would see
everybody's like I would buy one like
Deadpool kills the DC Universe who the
hell would buy that it'd be hilarious
yeah see everybody would like it'd be
amazing Deadpool kills the DC Universe
I'd buy the [ __ ] out of that I'd run to
the store and buy it so fast and make
your head spin oh man okay a couple more
questions guys and then we're gonna go
ahead and call it a night um let's see
who do I think will be cast as
spider-man well like I said I think acid
Butterfield is the only one that's going
to be cast what is your dream rule for a
Matthew McConaughey in the MCU and ever
go to little monsters comics and
Somerset Kentucky well Somerset's like
three hours away from me so no I've
never been there but Matthew McConaughey
in the MCU one I don't think he'd be a
good fit but two if you were mmm I don't
know I mean I couldn't really see
Matthew McConaughey in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe um let's see what
would I do with the Infinity Gauntlet oh
man what would I do with the Infinity
Gauntlet
I don't know I don't know what I would
do with the infinity gone but I change
the batteries out of this thing um let's
see I mean I've got I can do anything
like I can literally do anything with
the Infinity Gauntlet um well one I
would use a gauntlet - well no I don't
think I make myself immortal
I mean okay if you got the Infinity
Gauntlet what would you want with
anything I mean you could do literally
anything okay okay listen listen let's
enhance this question a little more
let's say that I had the Infinity
Gauntlet but I only have it for like
three hours then what would I do with
the Infinity Holland if I only had over
three hours um well I traverse the I
traversed the cosmos like I would
traverse the universe I would travel
around look at like all the systems and
all that kind of good stuff
and I would freeze time so that you know
time wouldn't pass over the course of
that three hours I don't know I mean if
that's a difficult question I ask that
takes some thinking because I don't I
want to stay away from the from the
normal subject I've just been ignoring
this troll on ignore neutrals um I try
to stay I'm trying to say away from this
stuff like well I would like I'd make a
really hot girlfriend you know and like
replace my current girlfriend you know I
would give myself like a trillion
dollars I mean you know I don't want to
do something like that I mean that'd be
kind of silly
let's see beyond you - what would you
what would you do with in the what would
I like to do within the comic book
industry honestly I'd like to be like a
comic book advisor for movies like
advised movie studios oncoming book
characters I don't really want to write
comics don't really want to like draw
comics is you know I don't want to
create stories it's not really my thing
I'd rather just be an advisor like I'll
rather you know work for Fox would be
like you know uh I guess on retainer for
Fox or for maybe like Marvel the Marvel
Cinematic Universe alone I doubt they
really need me so they have like
everybody producing from the from the
comic book writers you know I mean I'd
like to just be an advisor be like hey
guys like I do this different I do that
different you know if they like handed
me a script I could run over the script
and say okay here's some corrections
here's what I would you different but
you know again it'd be just just that
III think I'd enjoy that more I think
I'd have more fun doing that but kill
haters what do you think on a Galactus
movie in the MCU well I mean we won't we
won't get that I mean we're not gonna
get Galactus Galactus is a fantastic for
property we're never gonna see him so
let's see what's your favorite Marvel DC
TV show um definitely daredevil and
definitely probably this was actually a
toss-up between the arrow and and the
flash because they're both really solid
shows anyway guys I'm gonna go ahead and
hop here again make sure you guys check
out time on Magnus head over to Tyrone
Magnus his YouTube channel and just be
like Rob sent me here and I really like
comics explained sent me here and he
will be like he'd be like yes
you'll be like Thank You Magnus sites
he's really funny he's got some awesome
reaction videos but but anyway yeah so
I'm gonna go ahead and and bounce off
here guys and I don't we'll catch you
guys later peace